Dos hombres empezaron a operar Bitcoin el
mismo día. Uno pasó 12 horas al día
mirando velas, persiguiendo cada pequeño
impulso verde. Anoche, una sola trampa de
ballenas liquidó todos sus ahorros de vida. El
otro hombre cenó con su familia,
durmió tranquilo y despertó con una
ganancia de $5,000. La diferencia no fue
suerte. Fue el sistema. Uno era el
cazador, el otro era el defensor. La mayoría de
los traders fracasan porque juegan el
juego de las ballenas. Compran cuando les dicen
que compren, pero las ballenas están poniendo trampas
y tú eres la presa. Trap Defence BTC
cambia el juego al visualizar lo
invisible. Nuestro motor detecta
manipulación institucional antes de que
golpee tu P&L. Te damos la habilidad
definitiva del trading, la disciplina para mantenerte
a salvo hasta que las probabilidades estén a tu favor.
Es defensa de alta resolución para un mercado de
alto riesgo. Y hoy puedes equiparte
sin costo alguno. Únete a la
Defenders Academy ahora y obtén la
edición mínima del Trap Score de
forma gratuita. Sin tarjeta, sin relleno, solo la
verdad cruda del mercado. Deja de ser la
presa, conviértete en el defensor. Haz clic abajo
para iniciar el bot y reclamar tu acceso
gratuito ahora.